repo men brought to you by the repo men
training kit repo men is kind of like
repo the Genetic Opera but kind of not
okay so when repo men we live in a world
where for the price of a couple of
houses and an APR that makes a shitty
Sears Charge Card look like Capital One
Gold you can replace your shitty dying
organs with nice shiny synthetic ones
now the bummer is if you fall behind on
your payments the union will send a repo
man and knock at your door and reclaim
their property by ripping it out of you
yeah Jude law enforced Whitacre happened
to play a couple of those repo men and
as the trailer showed us something
happens to Jude Law where he receives an
artificial organ and he knows exactly
how this is all gonna play out which is
funny because that's kind of how you
feel in this movie not gonna lie this
movie's pretty predictable it's kind of
like Minority Report with less brains
and so when devoted repo man Jude Law
falls behind on his payments the
cat-and-mouse game between him and Ghost
Dog is on sounds cool right
it kind of was should have been more
cool though I mean they just could have
done more with that aspect I mean these
two have known each other since grade
school now they're on opposing sides of
a system a system that leads to death I
mean they touched a little bit on the
whole like I don't want to do this this
sucks but they touched way more on Jude
Law and that chick from I am Legend he's
kind of a waste and the directing was
weird this is really inconsistent you
know like it starts out kind of
sarcastic and funny and not like in
comedy kind of like Dexter directed by
Guy Ritchie with voiceovers I thought it
was cool and then goes from that to like
really morose and just kind of goes
nowhere it goes everywhere but it really
went nowhere and then back to sarcastic
with voiceovers and then back to serious
and then back to sarcastic and back to
serious and it was like it was directed
by two different people that's what it
felt like it felt like two different
directors were fighting over this movie
but in Minority Report light aka repo
men Jude Law and forest whitaker were
actually really good i liked them they
were a good duo it worked but it goes to
show you that good acting within an
average movie just comes out to good
acting within an average movie doesn't
make the movie any better but at the end
of this movie there's this one fight
scene between Jude Law and a few guys
that really reminded me of that slow-mo
knife scene from V for Vendetta but it
was badass because it involved knives
and hack saws and hammers it was your
basic death by the content of your dad's
toolbox scenario if that's basic and
Jude Law's wife was yeah useless and
like what's your problem I mean it's
like lady look yeah your husband rips
out people's organs leaving them
twitching and dying in a pool of their
own blood sure but come on I mean have a
heart oh oh yeah that was a heart joke
and by the end of this movie I mean
literally by the last frame I like the
movie enough but it's not enough for me
to sit here and say you need to see this
movie I mean I had solid acting and it
was a cool premise that was mixed with
wasted potential and consistent
directing and useless moments which I
suppose is kind of the same as wasted
potential number system it's about a 6
out of 10
maybe six and a half because of the very
end but that's my final answer
six and a half out of ten it let's face
it there's a reason these movies come
out in March and as a reminder I'm still
collecting donations for the Leukemia
and Lymphoma Society the link is in the
sidebar if you want to make a donation
even $1.00 well appreciate it all goes
towards a very good cause tearing
Leukemia and Lymphoma so thank you guys
for your time more vids to come
[Music]